digamos que tenemos la ecuación lineal e
igual a un medio de x menos 3 así que si
quisiéramos dibujar la línea que
representa el conjunto de puntos donde
sus coordenadas x y satisfacen esta
ecuación entonces podríamos empezar
dibujando algunos de esos puntos y
unirlos con una línea verdad porque esta
ecuación en el plano está representada
por una línea así que vamos a hacer eso
tenemos nuestra coordenada x nuestra
coordenada x y vamos a compararlo con la
coordenada y verdad entonces lo que
vamos a hacer es dar algunos valores de
x y obtener valores de y así que qué
pasa por ejemplo si nuestro si nuestro
valor de x es 0 verdad entonces este
término no aparece y solo nos queda
menos 3 ok entonces ya sería menos 3
ahora bien aquí tenemos un medio así que
multiplicamos por cosas que sean
múltiplos de 2 por ejemplo qué pasa si x
es 2
si x es 22 por un medio es 1 y uno menos
3 es menos 2 muy bien ahora ver qué pasa
si x es 44 entre 2 es 2 - 3 es menos uno
y de hecho ya con estos puntos es
suficiente para dibujar una línea de
hecho para dibujar una línea solo
necesitamos dos puntos muy bien entonces
vamos a graficar esos puntos en este
plano coordinado que tenemos entonces el
primero de ellos es el cero menos tres
entonces corresponde a este punto que
tenemos aquí el siguiente es el 2 menos
2 corresponde a este otro punto que
tenemos aquí y también tenemos el 4
menos 1 que es el punto que tenemos de
este lado entonces nosotros podríamos
intentar dibujar toda la línea verdad
simplemente uniendo esos puntos y más o
menos se vería al
así
más o menos de esta forma muy bien y ahí
tenemos más o menos la gran la gráfica o
la línea que representa a esta ecuación
lineal entonces está por supuesto vamos
a escribirlo esta es la gráfica de la
ecuación igual a un medio de x menos 3
muy bien entonces ahora que tenemos ya
esta gráfica cuando vemos una gráfica de
este estilo algo interesante es ver
dónde intersecta a los ejes muy bien
entonces el primero de esos puntos que
podríamos tratar de ver es la
intersección con el eje x verdad que es
el eje horizontal entonces podemos
observar que esa intersección se
encuentra en este punto muy bien en este
punto es la intersección con el eje x y
este punto en particular se le da un
nombre que es el de abscisa narcisa
al origen muy bien esta es la abscisa al
origen y por supuesto la coordenada es
el 60 verdad y entonces siempre que
veamos una recta que intersecta al eje x
el punto donde lo intercepta se le
conoce como abscisa al origen muy bien
en este caso la coordenada es 60 y por
supuesto que la coordenada en 0
justamente porque estamos sobre el eje x
muy bien y justamente el eje de las
abscisas también se le conoce al eje x
como el eje de las abscisas y por eso es
que este punto lleva este nombre muy
bien ahora otro otro punto que podríamos
preguntarnos es dónde intersecta esta
línea al eje y verdad y podemos observar
que este es el punto en donde
interceptamos al eje y de hecho aquí
está en la tabla verdad cuando x es 0
nos encontramos sobre el eje y el eje
vertical y ese es en el punto menos 3
verdad en la altura menos
sobre el eje y entonces a este punto de
forma similar como a la anterior se le
conoce como ordenada al origen y eso es
porque el eje y también se le conoce
como el eje de las ordenadas y ahora
bien este punto es el 0,23 muy bien ahí
tenemos tanto la abscisa como la
ordenada al origen
ahora bien en este punto también lo
podríamos verificar de nuestra ecuación
por ejemplo estamos pensando cuando x
vale 0 entonces tenemos que si cuando x
vale 0 tenemos cero y en ese caso que
vale menos tres el otro punto sería
cuando vale cero verdad entonces cuando
llévale cero tenemos que un medio de x
menos 30 es decir necesitamos un valor
de x que al dividirlo entre 2 y restarle
3 nos dé 0 entonces si x vale 6 al
dividirlo entre 2 a 3 y al restarle 3
nos da 0 entonces estos dos puntos los
podemos verificar directamente de
nuestra ecuación lineal muy bien ahora
que ya sabes cómo se encuentran las
ordenada y la abscisa al origen vamos a
hacer otro ejemplo muy bien digamos que
tenemos ahora la ecuación lineal 5x
6 ye igual a 30 y como siempre te invito
a que hagas una pausa y trates de hallar
por tu cuenta la ordenada y la abscisa
al origen de la gráfica que describe
esta ecuación que de hecho es una línea
así que ahora vamos a hacerlo juntos ok
y vamos a hacerlo poniendo nuestra
tablita bien pongamos una tabla en donde
tengamos los valores de x y los valores
de y ahora bien si nosotros queremos
encontrar la ordenada al origen okey
necesitamos que x tenga el valor 0
verdad entonces si x tiene el valor 0 de
este término ya no aparece y nos
preguntamos para qué valor de y al
multiplicarlo por 6 nos da 30 y el valor
de jake que al multiplicarlo por 6 nos
da 30 es 5 o que quizás debería quitar
antes esa línea y entonces ya vale 5 muy
bien qué pasa ahora si queremos
encontrar el la abscisa al origen eso es
cuando ya vale 0 entonces este término
no aparece y nos preguntamos para qué
valor de x al multiplicarlo por 5 nos da
30 y entonces vemos que sigue vale 0
entonces x tendría que ser 6 verdad
porque 6 por 5
30 entonces podríamos graficar estos
puntos tenemos el 05 tenemos este punto
de aquí y tenemos el 60 que coincide con
este otro punto de la línea verdad
entonces si nosotros queremos dibujar la
recta que pasa por esos dos puntos
podríamos hacer algo así
algo así y luego no sé es algo así para
pintar el otro lado
más o menos y ahí tenemos un dibujo de
la recta que satisface esta ecuación y
simplemente necesitamos dos puntos
verdad el primero de ellos es la
ordenada ordenada al origen al origen y
tiene coordenadas 0,5 verdad
este de aquí este de aquí es el punto de
la ordenada al origen y podemos observar
que también este punto el 60 coincide
con la abscisa al origen muy bien
entonces ahí tenemos otro ejemplo más de
cómo encontrar las intersecciones con
los ejes